you're watching the most advanced brain
machine interface in action
Kathy Hutchinson is paralyzed and unable
to speak but just by thinking she's able
to control the movements of this robotic
arm and drink her morning coffee she's
part of a pioneering study run by
researchers at Brown University in the
US people who are paralyzed
have their brain disconnected from their
body so they're not able to go out and
do everyday things that you and I can do
like reach for a glass of water or
scratch your nose and I think many of us
don't realize how debilitating it is
especially for people who have the
severus forms of paralysis
that's called tetraplegia where they
can't move their arms and legs because
there's been damage to the spinal cord
or a stroke that's cut the pathway from
the brain to the spinal cord so our idea
is to bypass that damaged nervous system
and go directly from the brain to the
outside world so the brain signals can
not control muscles but control machines
or devices like a computer or robotic
limb the trial is called brain gate the
team announced their first success in
2006 Matt Nagel was left paralyzed in
all four limbs after he was stabbed but
using the brain gate system he could
control a cursor on a computer screen
with his thoughts going to open the
first email which says congrats it says
you are doing a great job next I'm going
to open the second email which states hi
there it says hi we'll talk so I'm going
to the accent next I'm going to pants a
circle this kind of brain machine system
has been tested before in monkeys the
brain gate studies show that it works in
humans too
so how exactly does it work there are
three main components to any brain
machine interface your brain computer
interface there's a sensor there's a
decoder and there's a assistive
technology the sensor is a tiny array of
electrodes connected to a bundle of gold
wires it's implanted in the patient's
motor cortex the
of the brain that commands body
movements the brain activity recorded by
the sensor is relayed to a computer the
decoder and that then instructs the
assistive technology a cursor is one
thing but an arm is quite another
there's really a big challenge in moving
from moving a cursor on a screen which
sort of slides around in just one two
dimensions really on a flat surface to
controlling something as sophisticated
as a robotic arm that has a hand and an
elbow and a shoulder it can virtually
move around anywhere to design the arm
the brain gate team worked with robotics
experts in the US and Germany one big
challenge because no one wants a clumsy
robot was to make it react to its
environment so when it collides with a
target the bottle it grabs it but when
there's an unexpected collision it stops
moving and enters safety mode eventually
the researchers hope to build an arm
that works as smoothly as a real one and
can cope with more complicated tasks
like brushing teeth they'd also like to
make a wireless version so the device
doesn't need to be plugged directly into
the patient's head but for now they're
celebrating their progress with Kathy
all of us were standing in awe more or
less because we were watching her
drinking the coffee and it was really
such a stunning scene that was a special
moment for all of us so it was a magic
moment
in the nearly 15 years before before
that event every time she wanted to take
a drink of something caregiver would
need to place the cup of the bottle into
a into a holder that would be placed
near her wheelchair position that bottle
just right to see her with that robotic
arm reach out and pick up that cup of
coffee serve herself that coffee for the
first time in in the early 15 years it
was an incredible moment
you